MARKUS KLUTE: Now back to 8.701.
So in this section, we'll talk
about relativistic kinematics.
Let me start by saying that
one of my favorite classes here
at MIT is a class called
8.20, special relativity,
where we teach students about
special relativity, of course,
but Einstein and paradoxes.
And it's one of my
favorite classes.
And in their class,
there's a component
on particle physics, which
has to do with just using
relativistic kinematics
in order to understand how
to create antimatter,
how to collide beams,
how we can analyze decays.
And in this
introductory section,
we're going to do a
very similar thing.
I trust that you all had some
sort of class introduction
of special relativity, some of
you maybe general relativity.
What we want to do here
is review this content
very briefly, but then more
use it in a number of examples.
So in particle physics,
nuclear physics,
we often deal particles
who will travel
close to the speed of light.
The photon travels at
the speed of light.
We typically define the velocity
as v/c in natural units.
Beta is the velocity,
gamma is defined by 1
over square root 1 minus
the velocity squared.
Beta is always
smaller or equal to 1,
smaller for massive particle.
And gamma is always
equal or greater than 1.
The total energy of a
particle with 0 mass--
sorry, with non-zero mass, is
then given by gamma times m
c squared.
And the momentum is given by
gamma times mv or gamma times
m beta.
The total energy
squared of a particle,
considering one massive
particle, or one particle,
is given by energy squared
equal momentum squared
plus mass squared.
And if you now consider
a particle with 0 mass,
you see that the energy
and the momentum are equal.
If you consider a
particle at rest,
meaning the momentum is
0, you see that the energy
is equal to the mass.
You get Einstein's famous
formula, the energy is equal--
E equal m c squared.
Energy is equal to the
mass or the equivalence
between those two.
But we want to fully
understand and control
our Lorentz transformations.
Here shown for example, we have
a boost or a transformation
in x-direction.
So you see that
energy and momentum
transform like time and space.
And you just-- I really
encourage you to just review
this in more general
cases, but you can always,
when you have a boost
in one direction,
just do rotation and get to
this more simplified case.
So here is the first
example I would like
you to actually go through.
The Lorentz
transformation here, I
decided to use the z-direction,
just to change things up
a little bit.
And the velocity of the
boosted frame is vb.
So we want to calculate the
quantity m squared s squared
in the transformed frame.
And what you will find, if you
actually do the calculation--
and the solutions are
in the backup slides--
it's that z quantity
doesn't change
in the Lorentz transformation.
It is invariant.
And we'll talk about an
invariant mass in this context.
So now in particle
physics, we often
have the case that we
are not considering just
one particle and want to
describe just one particular
and measure it, but often
the case of particles,
or multiple particles, which
are involved in the reaction.
So we can look at the
total energy, just the sum
of the energy of all
particles, and total momentum,
the sum of the momentum
of all particles.
And those two quantities
are always conserved.
They are not invariant.
So be aware of the distinction
between conserved properties
and invariant properties.
Invariant here means
perform a transformation
like the Lorentz
transformation, and the property
doesn't change.
Conserved here means we have a
reaction, and in that reaction
the property is not changing.
Those are two different,
distinct things.
So now you can look at the
invariant property, or the one
which is conserved in
this collision, which
is this mass term or
mass-squared term.
The total mass, we'll
define this total mass as
equal to the energy squared
minus momentum squared.
And then you can
consider the two cases
of a laboratory frame and the
so-called center-of-mass frame.
So in the laboratory
frame, you have a particle.
It's moving when we
observe this particle,
and then it decays into, in
this example, three daughter
particles.
In the center-of-mass
frame in this example,
we put ourselves into the
rest frame of the particle
we are interested in.
And then that frame then,
three particles emerge.
And we can describe
the three particles.
So the momenta between the
three daughter particles
are not going to be [INAUDIBLE].
But because this total mass
is an invariant property,
it's the same in both frames.
And it's equal to the mass
of the parent particle
which we [INAUDIBLE] So when you
measure the energy and momentum
of the daughter particles, you
can infer in any frame the mass
of the parent particle by
calculating the total mass.
And so you can infer
from those measurements
the identity of the
mother particle.
And that's, for example, how
we discover the Higgs boson.
We measure the Higgs boson
decay into a pair of photons,
and then we calculate the
mass of those two photons
in our laboratory frame.
And that mass, then, is
equal to the Higgs mass.
So now here we want to compare
or look into those two cases
a little bit more.
The first case is a case
where we have a particle 1
colliding with a
particle 2, where
the particle 2 is at rest.
Particle 1 has a
certain energy E1.
And the second example--
this is called a
fixed-target experiment.
So the second particle is fixed,
the first one is colliding.
The second example is the one
where you have two particles,
and both have energies, and
we bring them to collision.
Often, the two
particles are in nature,
like two protons, an
electron and positron,
and the energies of
the beams are the same.
But this doesn't
have to be the case.
Later in the class, we'll
look at heavy iron collisions.
It's the collision of
heavy ions like lead.
It's a proton.
And here the masses
are different,
and the energy of the
particles can be different.
All right.
And here's another exercise now.
So we want to actually
create a Z boson, which
has a mass of about 91 GeV.
Note I dropped the c squared,
1 over c squared here.
And you want to produce
this particle colliding
a positron with an election.
This has happened at LEP at
CERN in the late '80s and '90s.
The center-of-mass energy, often
what's called square root of s,
is equal to 91 GeV.
So that's the energy
we need in order
to produce this new particle.
The mass of the electron
and the positron
are 511 KeV or 0.511 MeV.
So the energy needed
is 45 GeV, 45.5 GeV.
However, that was
the setup at LEP,
where you have two
beams colliding.
So we have this
center-of-mass energy
being given by the energy
directly given approximately
by the energy of the two beams.
So now, imagine somebody
would have proposed
a fixed-target experiment, where
you have stationary electrons,
for example electrons in
atoms, just a gas of some sort,
and then you have produced
positrons in a beam,
you accelerate them and
bring them to collision.
So the question now
is, how large does it--
do you need an energy
of this positron beam?
How large does it have to be
in order to produce a Z boson?
So again, this is
something I would
like you to actually
explore and just write down.
Solutions for this example
are also in the backup.
So now, you know,
there is a number
of interesting
examples just coming
from E equal m c squared,
and from being able to use--
and that can be
answered by being
able to use Lorentz
transformation.
And so now here I give you
just a set of examples.
And you should work on
them on your own time.
Maybe we'll touch on
them in recitation.
The first one is
rather straightforward.
Again, we are talking
about LEP at CERN.
After the Z bosons
were produced,
when it was trying
to go to high energy
to find some new physics,
some new particle, for example
the Higgs boson.
The Higgs boson
might be produced
by a process which is called
Higgs-Strahlung process.
We will look at this later.
So you have an
electron and a positron
colliding to virtual Z boson.
So that is a Z boson which
is heavier than 91 GeV.
We'll see later how
that's possible.
But then the virtual Z boson
can radiate a Higgs boson.
So that's why it's
called Strahlung,
like the German word for
radiation, Strahlung process.
And so electrons
and positrons were
accelerated to 100 GeV each,
center-of-mass energy 200 GeV.
What was the gamma factor
for those electrons?
Another question which
is quite exciting
is, how much energy
do you need in order
to split a proton and a
neutron, which is a bound state?
It's called a deuteron.
And it's a fundamental--
the important particle
in the evolution
of our universe,
in the sense that in order to
generate higher mass or higher
proton number
elements, a neutron is
rather important in this.
And so just by knowing
the mass of the proton,
the mass of the neutron, and
the mass of the deuteron,
you can now calculate how
much energy is in the--
binded-- what is the binding
energy between those particles.
We'll talk a lot about models
to calculate binding energy when
we talk about nuclear physics.
But here, just
from the kinematics
you can-- and from
E equal m c squared,
you can calculate
how much energy
needs to be in this
binded or compound state.
From atomic physics, you
might remember or know
that particles can--
excited particles
can emit photons.
And so now you have a particle.
It goes-- it [INAUDIBLE]
excites, radiates a photon.
What happens now to the photon?
I mentioned this happening in a
big gas or in some solid state.
Can the photon be reabsorbed
by the same medium,
or even by the same particle?
It's not a trivial
question, but what
is the conditions under
which-- so for example,
imagine you have a gas
as an excited particle.
And it emits a photon.
And so now the photon
sees the rest of the gas.
Can that rest of the
gas absorb the photon?
Interesting question.
It's not trivial.
Another interesting
question, I think,
is you're trying to produce
new forms of matter.
Like you just
produced a Z boson,
but you can also
produce antiprotons.
So what is the minimal energy
in a proton on a fixed-target
experiment--
so again, you have a target
of protons in some form,
you shoot a proton
against this target,
and you try to
produce an antiproton.
So that means that you
have to put produce--
in this collision, you have two
protons in the initial state,
you have to have a proton,
a proton, another proton,
and an antiproton
in your final state.
But what-- how much energy is
needed for the [INAUDIBLE] beam
in order to succeed
with this collision?
My counting is incorrect here.
So this should be
5, but OK, fine.
Decays.
So assume a pion decays at rest.
So a pion is at rest.
You look at a pion, that's
the compound state of meson
out of an up quark
and a down quark.
And it might decay in an
electron and a positron.
Whatever the dynamics
is in these decays,
if you just look at
the kinematics of this,
how fast are the decay products?
In order to calculate
that, you need
to look at the pion
mass, electron mass
we just discussed, and the
positron has the same mass.
So how fast are
electron and positron
coming out of a pion decay?
Assume that the pion is at rest.
And you can use
momentum conservation
and calculate the speed of
the electrons and positrons.
Again, one of those
minimal-energy proton
colliding experiments,
very similar setup.
But here we try to produce a
proton, a neutron, and a pion
out of proton-proton collision.
And then the last one is the
so-called Compton effect,
where you have a photon which
scatters of an electron target.
And so you have an
incoming photon,
and the electron is at rest.
And then you look at
the scattered photon
angle, scattered electron
angle, and in that collision
the energy of the photon
is going to change.
So the energy of the
photon is h times mu or h
over lambda, the wavelength.
And so the question is, how does
the wavelength of the photon
change in this
kind of condition.
So those are just
examples in how
you can use relativistic
kinematics in order
to calculate very important
aspects of collisions
in particle physics without any
understanding, at this point,
of the underlying dynamics,
the underlying forces,
the underlying conservation
laws, and so on.
So later in this
class, we'll discuss
what is the likelihood of a
pion to decay into an electron
positron, and why that is
actually not that likely.
And also, the collision
rates, lifetimes of particles.
But here we are just
looking at the kinematic
of those processes and calculate
how much energy is involved
and what is the momentum
of resulting particles.
So I'll stop here.
If you scroll down
on the slides,
you'll find solutions
to two of the problems.
And we'll discuss
them in recitation.